hi remember how a very long time I
uploaded a video about Advanced teror
painting involving the infamous checker
board technique that many roller coaster
Tyco 3 players use and it looks great
and honestly I would suggest anyone to
use it because it's so awesome and
basically I'm just going to explain it
real quick um for right now this is very
timec consuming honestly if you want to
build a roller coaster you're going to
have to cover the entire map or at least
the entire map where there roller
coaster goes with this little texture or
any texture that doesn't really um blend
with any other textures and then you're
going to have to make a checkerboard
pattern and start filling in and
this takes uh well a huge load of time
and it's also somewhat annoying it's a
it's a huge nuisance but of course as
you can see you get a really nice
texture and you can make any combination
and it's really awesome but if you don't
want to mix three or more textures
together using the checkerboard
technique because I would still
recommend doing that if you want to mix
multiple textures then there is actually
an easy way to get around this I just
found this on accident and using it as
of
lately and this is just some something I
thought I would share I would normally
not um make a sequel to a tutorial video
but this is an exception because this is
something that I want you to know uh so
that you can possibly save some minutes
of your life doing the checkerboard
technique even if you didn't have to do
it uh so basically this is the way it
works uh now this is very easy so pay
attention you're going to turn it on the
grid and you're going to just move the
cameras so that the lines are exactly
straight like that and then all you do
is you take your texture that you want
to mix and you start making vertical
stripes like this and there you go
that's how you do it uh oh wait of
course you should not mess up on it
there we go and as you can see this is a
very fast and easy way and it'll save
you a lot of time if you're making a
roller coaster and you want to use the
checker board technique so if you want
to make a roller coaster and you do want
some nice tan painting and you don't
really need to mix three or more
textures together because when you're
using it this way then it's a lot harder
to mix textes together than when you're
using a checkerboard pattern but in any
case when that's the case just use this
technique save yourself a lot of time
and you do something fun in those
minutes okay bye